I have something important to talk to
you about I want to take you on a little
journey maybe even a little date let's
set the scene someone you're interested
in you're infatuated with them they're
beautiful everything you could possibly
desire relationships can go great until
you see them involved when they're
eating when they're in the kitchen
cooking maybe how they're cleaning so
let's
begin okay the first one is putting
ketchup on everything
no
this is going to be a long day or a long
date gripping a fork with your whole
hand while you eat it
holy that's an ick I can't tell you how
fast I would walk I would I would D and
dash I would pay the bill and you know
appropriately tip and then I would Dash
using a fork on a non-stick pan ah I
would be willing to let this go because
my wife does it pronounces espresso as
espresso so I have actually left a date
for this before this has actually
happened to me that's an ick oh my
goodness listen listen you have to
respect yourself okay licking fingers
after touching raw chicken call a
therapist for that person you know do
something good contribute get the police
involved ah openmouth chewer that's an
ick a big one eats pizza with a fork and
knife you know it's a little weird but
maybe they're analytical you know maybe
they're very precise I like that I'll
say stick even though it's a little
weird eats their steak
medium This is highly dependent on if
you know what medium actually is most
people when they order medium what they
really want is they want an overcooked
well done steak people think medium
means a little bit of pink look I love
you but you just don't know what you're
talking about respectfully I would say
it's a stick because some steaks should
be cooked medium cooking the rice you
use used to dry your
phone bro what despicable bad knife form
okay look it's not your fault if you're
horrific at holding a knife that's fine
not everyone has training for it that's
a stick it's it's okay messy fridge look
I get it life happens I'm willing to let
this one slide sometimes my fridge is
messy kidding it's never messy wrong
ick
saying after every sip think about it
like this do you want to wake up to that
every single morning you're like sweet I
got your cup of Joe and then it's just
earpiercing often the distance echoing
through the halls of your
home you're never going to be able to
get away from it you're going to be
running out the door because it's an ick
[Music]
you better bet I'm picking it up and I'm
going to eat it anyway all right I'm
going to savor every last ounce of it so
contextually sometimes it's okay I I
would say it's a stick drinks a glass of
milk with their meals I think everyone
should be entitled to enjoy the things
that bring them joy and make their meals
more enjoyable this on the other hand
does not make your meal more enjoyable I
know there is something wrong something
deep and receding in this person's mind
there's actually one last icor stick I
have for you it's the biggest one yet if
they have this book
that this is the person you're going to
marry this is your soulmate that's a
stick now go off Frolic and I hope you
find your
soulmate
[Music]
bye